si chloroquine à n'est plus autorisée en
france pour soigner le kobe de 19 aces
une sage décision bruno retailleau pour
vous qui comptait parmi les grands
défenseurs des travaux du professeur out
non moi je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
d'études il ya d'ailleurs la fameuse
étude de dans la vie réelle du
professeur out avec un taux de mortalité
qui est très faible 0 5%
donc il ya plein d'études de par le
monde ya des études positives et
d'autres négatives j'observe que il ya
des études un peu sur papier qu'on
appelle big data avec des données etc et
d'autres études encore une fois dans la
vie réelle donc je préfère moi quand
même des études de la vie réelle et on
verra bien au bout du bout on fera le
point le compte de deux éléments quand
même de réponse la preuve le premier
élément c'est que moi j'ai toujours été
favorable à la prescription médicale
soit d'hôpital mais aussi par les
médecins généralistes est une liberté
fondamentale
il faut pas l'atteindre dans la mesure
où en plus cette politique ça fait 80
ans qu'elle existe
elle traite le paludisme elle a été
utilisée par des millions et des
millions d'êtres humains dans le monte
on ne connaît parfaitement les
contre-indications il faut les respecter
donc encore une fois ce n'est pas la
chloroquine qui tue c'est la pandémie
voilà il faut revenir à des choses assez
précise
il faut avoir le sens aussi bien sûr de
la mesure mais je pense que le dépanneur
à défendre les travaux du mais je pense
que je pense que le débat n'est pas clos
et ma position a toujours été de dire
attention sur une recul qu'on connaît
depuis longtemps qui a eu des effets
bénéfiques que sur un certain nombre de
maladies pour traiter aussi le paludisme
et autres on n'a pas le droit de
l'écarter d'un revers de main alors qu
on a nationalisé il ya plus de 3000
patients à marseille qui ont été
traitées avec des résultats et ces
résultats on peut pas les mettre par
dessus bord il existe et ça c'est une
étude dans la vie réelle c'est pas une
étude statistique donc moi je dis qu'il
ya l'empirisme c'est une voie de la
recherche
il ya une autre voie plus ce jour d'hier
abstraite qui mérite aussi d'être mené à
bien
mais au bout du bout je vais vous dire
ce qui départagera les uns et les autres
c'est le nombre de morts voilà ce sont
des résultats concrets tangible